this morning I was cruising around the
internets pat and i was on the david
pakman show reddit discussion forum at
david pakman.com slash reddit and some
very interesting discussions happening
there that i wanted to mention to you
i'll just go through a couple of them
here one is a post arguing that Donald
Trump's speech is irrelevant in the
sense that it doesn't really change who
or what Donald Trump is and his ability
to lead and a number of people jumped in
on that discussion I think there's a lot
of very good point being made here which
is whether or not you jump in with those
who said the optics of the speech were
good Trump appeared presidential as we
talked about earlier today the guy lied
51 times during a 61 minute speech and
it doesn't fundamentally change who he
is as someone that will be doing policy
for the next four years I think it's a
very good point yeah but I think this is
just kind of what they do during these
joint sessions of Congress they they go
over the past few months and recap their
accomplishments or what they tout to be
accomplishment yeah and then they lay
out their agenda going forward also from
the reddit discussion forum a Georgia
couple sentenced for racists threats at
a child's birthday party a truly truly
bizarre story and when you actually read
it you would argue you could argue as
one user did that they got off easy I
won't spoil the story for you but that's
a discussion at david pakman.com slash
reddit that i highly recommend you check
out also catching my eye a question
about whether male to female transgender
individuals should be allowed to compete
in female sports there was recently a
story which i don't know if you saw pat
about a female to male wrestler who had
started taking male pesta had started
taking testosterone but based on the way
the rules were written still only
allowed to wrestle other women which
provided a significant advantage as you
can imagine this sort of an opposite
discussion and 67 comments on this story
as of this morning and this is sort of a
side from issues of
discrimination and transgender rights
the sports questions actually come up
pretty frequently it's a very difficult
issue too because it's one of those
times where equality and fairness
conflict and it's kind of like you have
to choose one or the other you think I
mean it then I it's hard to find a
middle ground I think it's hard I think
that that's a better way to say it what
what is the middle ground how do you
define a middle ground in these
situations and a pretty there's a little
bit of trolling going on is they're
typically as always but pretty good
discussion happening at david pakman.com
slash reddit also from our reddit
discussion forum someone catching a
screenshot of me with a very very
unusual expression on my face and saying
titling it my face one the best insult a
troll can come up with during a live
stream is jus cuck and for people who
haven't checked out my youtube live
streams and they're all archived so you
can check them out after the fact very
often I am trolled with people either
making anti-semitic comments about me or
calling me a cuck and sometimes those
get combined into something like a Jew
cuck and yeah I feel like somethin on
trolls do get a kick out of that being
such a frequent thing which is it's not
really an argument well I mean you
absolutely look elated in this mode I
just won the lottery or something yes
indeed and lastly I believe we have one
more here for you the I voted 17 coupon
code is the bit anti green card holder
ish suggesting i assume partially
jokingly we have this coupon code that's
available for a big discount off of
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership and the coupon code is i
voted 17 and the implication is your
sort of being discriminatory against
people who can't vote in the United
States either because they're not
citizens or because they're not American
at all even though the coupon code is I
voted 17 you don't have to be an
American citizen to use it it doesn't
matter if you actually voted in the 2016
election you can use it regardless of
nationality sexual orientation gender
voting status whatever it would be a
good criticism if it was true but it's
not true exactly that's exactly right
please do subscribe to our reddit
discussion forum very quickly closing in
on
thousand of our viewers and listeners
participating there on a daily basis I'm
in there Pat checks it out great source
of stories and discussion for the show
david pakman.com slash reddit that's re
d di t